parallels is an incredibly useful
software for all Mac users and recently
it served me extremely well when I
needed to run Revit however that got me
thinking what if we'd use Parallels for
archicad D5 render enscape and even
SketchUp alright so we have Windows 11
open on our Apple MacBook studio with
the M1 chipset to prove my point I'm
simply going to come across about this
Mac and there we go we have the M1 Ultra
64 gigabytes of memory and we're using
the Ventura
13.2.1 current software
I have Windows 11 open running parallels
so parallels simply download it install
it away you go first of all we're going
to try run arcad 26 on windows 11. so
let's open it up and see what we get to
all right so far so good we're able to
start our CAD live and we're able to try
and sign in so let's go ahead and try
sign in to rcad 26 and download our
software key so so far so good once
again we've been able to sign into our
graphisoft ID we've been prompted for
our commercial license so let's run the
license manager tool and see if we can
once again sign in download our license
all right so we've come up against our
first roadblock in this test first of
all archicad does not allow you to
download your software key onto a
virtual machine now that's problematic
because most of our tests are going to
be run through arcad so unfortunately
we're going to have to quit out of our
Cad and go through a completely
different route to try to test all of
these softwares but for starters running
parallels and icad 26 through the window
those virtual machine not a great start
alright let's try and move on to D5
render which is an incredible software
that unfortunately I'm unable to use
with this Mac at the moment it is not
supported on the Mac system whatsoever
apple does not support across any of
their devices so we're trying to run it
on parallels let's go ahead and open up
D5 render let's run it as administrator
to try get maximum use out of it first
of all we have to run our benchmarks and
obviously we're not running a Windows
machine so this is definitely going to
be interesting to see what results we
get let's hit that start button and let
that load very rapidly which is again
once a good start alright so it seems
like we do not have the minimum
requirements to run D5 renderer through
the parallels machine but that's okay
this one I knew I was going to come up
against and I have a workaround so let's
go ahead and close that open up our
taskbar for the Windows Virtual Machine
make sure all d5s are closed completely
which they are right click on the icon
D5 renderer open up the file location
next we're going to search for config
double click on config and at the very
bottom where you see first open check
equals zero we're going to change that
zero to a one if you don't have any of
those details there just type that in at
the very bottom of the config file we
can go ahead close that close that and
now we can try to run D5 renderer once
again as administrator as you see we're
automatically prompted without the
Benchmark testing which means we can
actually use D5 render on our system
I've gone ahead and downloaded this
minimalist living room by Andrew whoever
Andrew is thank you your legend for
uploading this so let's give this a go
and see what performance we can get out
of the virtual machine now this is
taking a little while to load which
again is seeming relatively reasonable
because it is a large file so hopefully
what we open here is actually going to
be really useful for us and we're going
to be able to use D5 on a brand new Mac
Studio Ultra alright so we're able to
get in and load The Beginner's Guide
which is a good start let's just close
that off and what I'm noticing is just a
very blank white screen so obviously the
hdri sky is a little bit wrong if we
change it to Geo and Sky we're not
actually seeing too much we're meant to
see this full in preview but in fact all
we're seeing is some curtains a little
bit of fire and whatever this is meant
to be I believe it's meant to be a light
source which it is all of our objects
just aren't showing so if I try to move
adjust
nothing actually occurs we don't seem to
have any of these objects actually on
our screen so I'm guessing the fact that
it isn't recognizing the graphics card
is letting us down here we can see that
if we come a little bit closer to these
curtains it is trying to raytrace this
using the actual software it has
available to it if I come way too close
it disappears and drops it out this
isn't a very good Ray Trace
representation so obviously the system
just isn't able to run D5 renderer
without a good cable graphics card
through the virtual machine so
unfortunately we have another loss for
the virtual machine now I have a
pre-modeled SketchUp file that I've
exported out of arcad on the actual Mac
Software System and dragged it across
the virtual machine so let's double
click this file here try open up with
SketchUp and see how we go the main goal
here is to run it through enscape and
compare it to the results we can get out
of the Mac system which is just been
released with enscape to what we can get
out of the power of those machine
ideally the parallels machine is going
to be significantly better because it's
already optimized for Windows but let's
see how we go now if you watched my last
video comparing enscape to Twin motion
you recognize this house if you don't
I'll link up top so you can watch that
video as well but for now we're going to
try and take this model here and import
it directly into enscape through the
parallels machine so very simple we come
up the top extension enscape hit the
start button 14 days free trial of
course so let's click continue trial see
how we go so far so good chaos loading
but then everything disappears so what
happened there let's try that once again
so we're going to come back up to
extensions and skate start and Escape
seems to crash every time we seem to
load Okay so
all right so once again we're having
another complete and utter fail with the
parallels machine basically anything to
do with Graphics intensive requirements
is just crashing and burning it is not
letting us do what we're trying to do
and it's not letting us accomplish
anything so even though archicad runs
perfectly fine on a Mac and you can
install it on a Windows Virtual Machine
you can't download the license key D5
renderer can't be installed on the Mac
system natively but it can be installed
through the parallels which is a great
start but the graphics card systems let
us down finally SketchUp runs perfectly
fine on both systems I see no issues
here running the SketchUp model it
probably runs a little bit slower
because it's through the virtual machine
rather than natively but not a big deal
if you wanted to do that for whatever
reason you could enscape plugin not so
good the fact that it is now available
natively on the Mac allows you to
definitely utilize that a lot better and
actually get your renders to a higher
quality so my verdict is very simple
stick to the native apps for the mac and
hopefully everything becomes native on
the M1 chipset very very soon anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video if you did make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below but
like always I'll see you next Monday